[Music]
this scene is a really important
pivot point in the film it's when the
children are realizing that they're not
on a family road trip the stakes of the
film really jump up another level
and you know they're having this
father-son moment they're bonding
cracking jokes
when a state trooper turns up
take in the car
it's okay
we immediately have a thinking feeling
on our stomach that this encounter is
going to go south my boys
are starting the state trooper is being
a little bit difficult he's pulling him
up on something quite small didn't think
to put your hazards on
and there was nobody on the road
i was on the road
you're right what we're not sure about
is has there already been a report of
missing kids that have been kidnapped
and um there's this kind of standoff
it's a little road trip huh uh-huh
at 3 a.m
yeah you know the early bird
with a scene like this where the the
tension slowly ratchets up we wanted the
camera actually to be quite patient and
let the dynamic between the characters
kind of drive the scene sir i want you
to put your hands on the back of that
car
yeah there ain't no need for that i got
an easy way or a hardware speech prepare
if you really want to hear there's a
really strong power imbalance and as
soon as dash's character puts his
hand on his gun you know it really it
just changes the dynamic i think there's
a good example of a moment in the film
where the stakes are raised by michael's
casting choices of a family that looks
like this
so you're a pervert for this firearm
not on me
the law enforcement would maybe be more
mistrustful of and vice versa
that against the law i saw michael
pierce's first film beast and i was
blown away so i asked what he was doing
next i got the script and then i started
stalking him so do you have any other
weapons in the vehicle i just said to
him listen if you cast someone like me
in this role it's gonna add layers it's
gonna add stakes it's going to be
unexpected and i think he has something
different in mind to begin with
the part was effectively written for a
white character he lobbied for it we met
several times but it didn't take much
convincing and i've always found him
such a
dexterous actor like he can really keep
you on the edge of your seat full of
grit and determination and fortitude and
so i knew he could credibly play a
marina
he has that warmth i think he could i
knew we could make that father-son story
feel compelling on screen when people
think of a
u.s marine or a special forces
soldier they might not think of someone
who looks like me
and for that reason
i i really wanted to play the role
and i know that if i'm going out of my
comfort zone i'm taking audiences out of
their comfort zone
and that's really what i want to do with
my work
it escalates the tension
with the people he meets on the road and
it increases the alienation that his um
him and his children feel from the world
around them there's also something
quietly groundbreaking culturally about
this farm
walk away
casting dash i didn't want to cast
someone who seemed explicitly sinister
you know there's something really
warm about dash he's a very likable guy
class a misdemeanor if it's loaded
you couldn't quite read
the trooper's motivations it's at that
point that he reveals that he is a
special forces veteran officer i'm a
marine special forces that just came
back off deployment what's so beautiful
is the way that both dash and rizz play
the scene they find a lot of subtle
nuances uh between the lines and in the
subtext beneath the lines just trying to
see my kids you know we did a bunch of
takes and did have a lot of fun because
it's a kind of mind game between the two
of them i only got him for the weekend
so that's why i'm driving at night just
trying to make up for time we use real
sounds of insects and we also developed
some rhythmic resonance of a heartbeat
in there there's some of jed kurtz's
school that's starting to flutter and
grow within the soundscape and that's
also helping to build the tension turn
around
real slow we seem like we might be at
that point where his
military background means a state
trooper is gonna give him a free pass
when malik notices something in the
state trooper's eye
we go from a very observational approach
to a very subjective one really slow it
down and we do that several times in the
film where we're really trying to get in
ruse's character's pov both his
psychological pov but also his literal
pov to see what he sees
at this point malik is convinced that
there are these non-terrestrial
microorganisms infecting people and
turning them evil and controlling them
and this is what he sees in the state
trooper's eye
get my id you can ride me a ticket i'll
be on my way stop right now put your
hands on your head and get down on your
knees
get your hands on your head and get down
on your knees now
your suspicions are confirmed it's not
just that this guy's a cop trying to
give him a hard time he's an infected
alien cop
it was really hard seen to shoot because
i think we shot this late november we
were on the side of a mountain
it was freezing
it was so ridiculously cold filming at
night it could have been anywhere we
could have done it in a nice warm studio
but i think michael wanted something
very grounded with this film and so
if the scene takes place halfway up a
mountain we're going to do it halfway up
a mountain
we had to do many tastes because there
was a stunt
element to it and um it was really hard
on the actors luckily dash and rizz uh
tough guys so
they were they were happy to do it i
just remember being in like
in just pain you know just like even
trying to like move your fingers felt
like they were icicles
it was pretty intense but the kids you
know they were they were heroes they
went with it
and i thought okay if these guys are
doing it and
i guess i have to keep going action
i think when
sunrise came
everyone was really glad to be to be
done with the scenes
we realized the kids needed to be in the
car and ducking low
and they only had to be there for the
first few hours and of course it made
sense behaviorally that they were going
to try and hide from the altercation as
it escalates
when we see the red and blue lights
flashing over them we know that if a
bullet goes off or ricochets across the
tarmac it could go into the window and
hit them
and that also
helped create tension
we wanted the lighting to feel very
grounded and real and sometimes lighting
light exteriors can be really hard
because if it's too dark you're not
seeing anything if it's too bright it
just looks phony and so we had this
ambient moonlight but also fluttering
lights of the trooper's car is pulsating
when blue light flicker over their faces
there's an anxiety that comes with that
and it creates a certain type of
rhythm uh in the scene you okay
yeah
and yeah that was another part of the
arsenal of tools we were using to create
tension
throughout the whole film you're kind of
asking yourself
what's real and what isn't up until this
point it's been more of an unseen threat
but now it's what seems like an infected
human shooting a gun at a car
electrocuting your dad the threat
becomes very very real
[Music]
the sequence starts with wiz phoning his
ex-wife and telling her that he's
leaving their kids at this uh this diner
at the edge of a desert and it's a
really painful phone call for him to
make we wanted to cover it in quite a
simple way and to leave space for his
performance the way that michael shot it
he wanted malik to be very much alone
and isolated in this no-man's land in
the frame just looking off into the
distance unsure of
which direction he should go in and so
we just set up a track beside the phone
box and i said to riz that once he
finishes the call just to find his own
his own beats uh and his own timing um
and that he could come out the phone box
whenever he wanted
and he could walk as
far as he wanted
as he made this journey towards a diner
and each take was slightly different and
the camera team just had to be really
attuned to his movements and his rhythms
and yeah it was i just love you know
where it's possible to give the actors
the room to find their own rhythm in a
scene and for the camera to be the one
that's really following them
with riz he always offers up something
different he said at the beginning of
our shoot that he likes to make mistakes
and i thought that's great because it's
something that i usually say to an actor
like i want you to make mistakes because
that's the only way that we're going to
find something interesting the only
thing with risk when you go through the
rushes it's really hard to see those
mistakes because everything's different
but everything's good
[Music]
i could do you know
dozens of cuts of this movie
uh and that would have an equally
compelling performance this really
offers up a lot of gifts for a director
the scene we felt it was important that
he held a lot back
okay i've got good news and bad news
so this scene happens towards the end of
the film and it's when malik realizes
that he's suffering from a
psychotic delusion of some kind the
threat isn't actually infection by
aliens and parasites the threat is
probably him
um he keeps putting his kids in danger
so at that point he makes the decision
to
you know turn his kids over and usually
i've got to keep fighting
and it's a heartbreaking moment for many
reasons for malik i think on one level
he's obviously saying goodbye to his
kids he'll probably never be able to see
them again after this and on another
level i think his whole sense of who he
is is shattered we realize he's gonna be
trying to put on a brave face for his
kids i'm gonna miss your dad
i'll miss you too
three musketeers we felt that it was
gonna be more interesting if he held
back emotionally he has to try and hold
it together because that's the one thing
he realizes he's been unable to do
he has not been holding it together
mentally and now
he has to try and put them first rizz
just does such a great job he's got that
simmering under the surface jay already
knows at this point there is no secret
special mission and um
malik knows this and then he tries to
send him a veiled message
to look out for his brother
thank
you scenes like this we're also using
two cameras because i wanted to allow
the children to
improvise where they saw fit
working with river on this scene his
character doesn't have any dialogue it
all had to be about him studying his
father so much of good acting
is really listening to the other actor
ice cream you can have as much as a
goddamn one
do you really mean it working with
aditya and lucian river
it was just such a joy such a privilege
they're such incredible young actors i
was just being led by them really you
know just looking into their faces and
realizing that what his kids need isn't
just soldier fighting against evil
what they need is just
a loving
stable dad
and at that moment
he doesn't think that he can be that it
really also just feels like a family
unit at this stage in the film and so
it's even more painful that they're
having to say goodbye to each other
[Music]
you